[Music]
thank you
hey friends Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
guide you through some interesting and
Innovative cap ideas I've been playing
with but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca becklinen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
all right so POI caps caps stands for
continuous assembly pattern and there's
a whole lot of them out there for the
most part when people think about caps
they're thinking about these patterns
right here this is what's called a c-cap
where I'm just moving my hands back and
forth along a c-shaped path and
switching the POI back and forth between
anti-spin and extension this is not the
only application for caps though in
addition to c-caps we also have s-caps
where we can move our hands back and
forth in an s-shaped hand path and as I
pointed out in a past video we can also
think of 1.5 as being a type of cap
namely a type of cap where we're
switching back and forth between a Move
That is supposed to be a three beat Move
versus a Move That is supposed to be a
two beat move which of course the
venerable c-cap that started the whole
cap craze also happens to be a type of
cap that moves between a three beat move
and a single beat move that is when I'm
doing the extension side of it I'm
really just doing a single beat move
there's only one point where the POI
goes below my hand and when I'm doing
the anti-spin part of it it's meant to
be half of a four petal anti-spin flower
in which there are one two three
downbeats that is points where the POI
goes beneath my hand so we go back and
forth between a three beat move one beat
move three beat move one beat move just
like we do when we're playing around
with our 1.5s here which if you want to
catch up on a couple years worth of tech
POI goodness I will go ahead and leave
links to the videos where I was
exploring these ideas so you can catch
up on them down in the description as
well as up on screen in the cards if
you're watching on YouTube and this
little QR code down here that you can
scan if you're watching this on a
television but as I was playing around
with those three to one caps something
jumped out to me that I hadn't
considered before and that was that
though those caps were moving back and
forth between two different patterns
that had different number of downbeats
to them it was also possible to go back
and forth between different types of poi
patterns that have the same number of
downbeats to them unfortunately this
does not result in a zillion different
permutations or combinations like the
three to one caps do in fact there's
really only two options here because
we're basically moving back and forth
between uh moves where the POI can be
pointed inward on the sides versus
outward so I want to take you through
four different POI moves right quick
that are all single downbeat and show
you how they can mix and match with each
other
first and foremost we have extensions
now as I'm doing this extension which
you know again it's a single downbeat
move and basically the POI is an
extension going out from my arm note
that the POI is outside of the hand path
on either side that is both on my left
as well as on my right it's pointed out
away from me now if I switch to doing a
vertical linear isolation once again
this is a single downbeat move there's
only one point at which the POI goes
beneath my hand and it happens to be at
the very very bottom now unlike the
extension I'm now working in a place
where both on the left as well as the
right side the POI is pointing back
inward towards Body Center
next and this is going to be really
challenging I'm going to try and do a
horizontal linear isolation
I'm not going to get this perfect but
the intention is basically to have the
POI head moving back and forth in a
straight line horizontally as my hand
traces out a big circular hand path like
so now again just like the extension
you'll note that when my hand is on
either side the POI is pointing out away
from my body
now the final pattern is really really
really difficult to keep going
permanently but I'm going to try anyway
this is a point isolation and the idea
here is that you're trying to keep the
POI head locked in the middle the entire
way around uh generally speaking we
don't do full reps of this we'll like
use it for example as a way to go
through like half of a circle whether it
be under
or whether it be over but nonetheless
just like the vertical linear isolation
this involves keeping that POI head
straight towards Body Center when the
hand is on either side so because
gravity is unfortunately a thing I know
it's a problem I'm working on it we
really only have two ways that these
four moves can be combined together
because after all if I'm performing an
extension there is absolutely no point
at which the POI is pointing Inward and
therefore there is absolutely no way
that it can be combined with a point
isolation
likewise when I'm doing a point
isolation the POI is always pointed
Inward and so there's no point where it
can where it can be combined with an
extension likewise when we talk about
the movements of both these vertical
linear isolations as well as horizontal
linear isolations we need points in them
both when they're pointing inward as
well as outward so so we can only mix
and match those patterns that match the
inward facing points and the outward
facing points on the side which those
two options are drum roll please
number one
yeah for those of you out there who are
already familiar with this pattern this
probably feels a little underwhelming
this is just commonly referred to as a
pendulum or if we're going to get real
spicy about it and extendulum that is
the hand is moving around the same path
that it would if it were performing an
extension but we always keep the POI
dangling beneath our hand but yeah
technically we can think of this as
being a cap we can think of it as
switching back and forth between an
extension
and between a linear isolation that is
the horizontal one because once again
they match up with the POI pointing out
to either side our other option which is
a bit more exotic looks like this
essentially we take a point isolation
across the top and we do a vertical
linear isolation across the bottom once
again my hand is tracing out the exact
same path that it would if I were doing
the other version of this that is the
extendulum but now the POI is always
oriented towards the middle on the sides
so what exactly can we do with this
knowledge well I'd say the first thing
is to learn all these patterns in all
the different modes of timing and
Direction so you've probably already
done the work of learning how to do your
extensulums in together same as well as
together opposite
as well as probably split Time same
direction
and of course
split time opposites right and if not
well you should catch up on that yeah
and of course we can learn all four
modes of timing and Direction with the
other one-to-one cap as well so we can
start off in together Time same
direction
foreign
and then learn together time opposites
[Music]
split Time same direction
and split time opposites
so I know there's not as much to learn
here and the results are a little
underwhelming but I think the true
potential here comes in the form of
hybrids that use one of each pattern
together so for example as I'm playing
with these extendulums here in together
Time same direction I can just as easily
swap back and have one of my POI doing
the inside version that is the point
isolation versus
vertical linear isolation version and
all of a sudden there's a really cool
interference pattern that comes out of
this likewise when I do it in together
opposite that same kind of cool
interference pattern effect shows up as
well
[Music]
I'll be honest with you I'm still not
entirely sure what's going on in Split
Time same direction but I think it still
looks cool
likewise split time opposites has a
really cool effect to it yeah I'm a fan
of all of them
[Music]
so this is definitely not essential
learning if you're a POI spinner but I
do think that it's still cool and I
really like the fact that there's still
stuff that I'm uncovering as I explore
caps so I hope that you enjoy exploring
them too and never fear there is
actually one more video coming on this
subject as I dive deeply into the world
of caps so keep your eyes peeled because
this one is a real weird one thanks so
much for watching did you get anything
out of this video please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support if you out there
watching are interested in learning how
to support my work too you can do that
by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission of bringing POI spinning and
flow watch to the whole wide world so go
check that out please and thank you and
to get the skinny on all the cool work
that I've been doing with caps I'll go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube the YouTube
algorithm also thinks that you might
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look as well thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace